[موسيقى]
القصف الاسرائيلي الجوي والمدفعي متواصل
على مناطق مختلفه في قطاع غزه وقد استهدف
هذا اليوم مناطق في شمال مدينه غزه تحديدا
حيي الدرج والتفاح لكنه يتركز بالاساس في
هذه المنطقه التي تقع الى الشمال من منطقه
جحر الديك منطقه المراقه وقد اغار عليها
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي هذا اليوم اكثر من
مره وكذلك استهدفت بالقصف المدفعي ونحن
نرى اثار هذا القصف المتكرر من خلال هذا
الدخان سحب الدخان المتصاعده طيله الوقت
ومن الواضح ان هناك حدث معين يجري لانه
تكرر ان تم استهداف هذا الموقع بالتحديد
عده مرات سواء كان بالقصف الجوي او القذف
المدفعي الى جانب ذلك ايضا كانت هناك عده
غارات استهدفت المناطق الوسطى في قطاع غزه
تحديدا ما نستطيع ان نرصده من هذا الموقع
هذه الغارات في منطقه مخيم البريج لكن
ايضا طيله الوقت تسمع اصوات انفجارات في
مواقع تقع الى الشمال والى الجنوب من هذه
المنطقه في منطقه الصيرات وايضا المغازي
ومنطقه الزوايدي وبالتالي هذا القصف
متواصل صوت نيران
ودوي الانفجارات لا يتوقف على الاطلاق في
مناطق الوسط وفي مناطق الجنوب وايضا في
هذه المنطقه التي تقع تماما عند ما يعرف
بوادي غزه لكن ايضا في المناطق الشماليه
هناك عمليات تفجير واسعه ينفذها سلاح
الهندسه في جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لما
تبقى من منشات ومبان سكنيه ومنازل لم تت
دمر جراء القصف المدفعي والجوي في هذه
الحرب نجوان سمري الجزيره من الحدود مع
غزه